what made the American people so willing
to have such an a bloated administrative
State yeah it was a sort of laziness in
our culture it actually started with
laziness of the elected officials right
so
initially the way it was supposed to
work was the people who showed up in
Congress and in the U.S Senate they're
supposed to have the actual lawmaking
Authority but also accountability
they started to get a little lazy with
that accountability these bills get into
the specifics of those details that's a
little too hard to deal with
presidents who we elected in the White
House started to similarly get lazy
saying that well you know the budgeting
process I'm supposed to ask Congress for
permission to spend money it's a little
too complicated let me delegate that
down
so it was sort of a dual delegation
the president United States started to
get a little lazy Congress started to
get a little lazy they said let's just
create this third party apparatus three
letter agencies
where we don't actually have to be
accountable for the result because we
can blame it on them if things go badly